during his time in the armed forces it
was clear prince harry was in his
element
risking his life to serve on the front
line it wasn't done in the wrong way but
it was just
whenever it was required
the duke undertook two tours of
afghanistan during his 10 years of
service
before eventually rising to the rank of
captain
that title is not affected but his
ceremonial roles
are one former superior says
relinquishing them
would not have been easy to give those
up will be painful for him
because he will have known how important
they are for
soldier sailors airmen and marines and
that he will no longer be there
to be not just their figurehead but
their leader their example and their
inspiration
and that's tough harry took over as
captain general of the royal marines
from the duke of edinburgh in 2017
and was even prepared to defend his
dedication to the role in the courts
last year
successfully suing the publisher of the
mail on sunday and mail online
after they falsely claimed he'd snubbed
the royal marines in stepping down
from royal duties david wiseman is a
fellow veteran
and helped harry set up the invictus
games he says the respect
goes both ways i i just know that that a
lot of people are very very thankful for
the service that he has
um uh performed over you know the past
couple of decades
and the amount of time and energy that
he's personally put into not only his
military service but also
also the support he's given and i think
that buys him a huge amount of respect
harry set up the invictus games in 2014
to support
wounded service men and women in their
recovery he's never been
shy in showing his passion for the
project and tonight the foundation
confirmed he will remain
a private patron an association it said
it is proud of
the pride prince harry had in his
honorary roles in the forces was obvious
giving them up for me losing a lot more
from the accompanying outfits
and titles either bennett sky news